[Music]
Mila Kunis Kristen Bell and their bad
mom's Christmas co-stars stunned at the
film's LA premiere Monday just one day
before Halloween
Mila and Kristen told et they celebrated
the spooky holiday early and had one
thing in common what you going
Elsa what you one is also cave on those
we send each other photos neither of you
were ever know Mike at white-white six
months ago I was like buddy what do you
want to be for Halloween she's like I'm
gonna be Cinderella and you're gonna be
Elsa apparently both moms dressed up as
the frozen princess against their will
Kristen posted this pic and said her
daughter demanded they wear Elsa
costumes instead of her character Anna
you Jake appreciates me I did and she
was like money you have to be Elsa
Foley's because I wouldn't be else and
she really likes matching okay like she
was wearing a green dress I say so I
chose green eyeshadow like we have like
a thing no no I said don't you want to
be on and she was like she just doesn't
and I had that blonde wig on I make a
beauteous Elsa like the world's most
unattractive human being
oh my god I was dying walking down the
neighborhood like Jagger tree
[Music]